article about have you ever heard of you
guys ever heard of burial pods nope
so basically this company and now
instead of coffins they put you in this
biodegradable like capsule and they put
the dead human body in like a fetal
position in a biodegradable capsule and
they which can be then planted
underground and then a tree can or it's
like you can have you can plant like a
seed and then have a tree grow on top of
that capsule so like now if they're
called burial pods are really
cool-looking
so now Lego and so the family can take
care of the trees water the trees and
watch it grow I don't give no it's not
kind of like already [ __ ] stupid
house it I'm gonna do what welcome to
Disney did that makes freeze my body in
a thousand years from now when you
figure out what was wrong with me
unfreeze me and fix my [ __ ] I don't want
to be a tree [ __ ] no you're not the
tree but you're nourishing a tree to
grow I don't care our body right your
body that's d call composing is this
question am i dead you're dead as [ __ ]
well then that's it that's it I don't
give a [ __ ] you know what how about that
you realize do you think Walt Disney is
dead it is not Vettes [ __ ] no he's not
he's frozen
so before ok this is my question so
before his organs actually started to
decompose they were able to to to
suspend his the decomposition cryogenic
in a state that a hundred years from now
could possibly be brought back to life
yep oh I want that then you know mean he
as soon as he that he frozen right and
then when they unfreeze when they have
the technology to do it yeah it could be
from a hundred years from now whatever
yeah you'll be walking around and is
like he's gonna create dude characters
I'll be great because the ones he has so
right now stale right Mickey Mouse all
that [ __ ] yeah you get some new [ __ ]
you know man yeah but like oh that's
what I would do this [ __ ] part
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] I think all and you
can have like instead of like flat
cemeteries with um gravestones you can
just have a forest or what about this
why don't you chop my
little pieces right and then bake it in
as a dumpling right and then you go to a
koi fish pond and just throw it in there
and see if they eat it interesting same
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] boy if you don't eat
anything I want to be I want to be
mounted on a wall just like Oh cries I
know you know what I want yeah that's
great
what do you want half your body half
like I'm on an angle bah I'm on an angle
is like a half body with wings you know
it's like in Filipino mythology that's
like what we're afraid of but we're like
made to be afraid of when we're children
and it's a it's lies it's a hat it's
just has half a body and has wings I
want to be mounted like am on an angle
on someone's wall when I die never
people will say that in my life yeah
perfect you guys did it well you know
what I want what this is what I'm gonna
I swear to God I want this okay
as soon as I die I want them to put me
in a gigantic jar of formaldehyde
but buffet before they put me in there
though you gotta put me in a tuxedo I
need to be in a tuxedo and a little top
hat that doesn't you know mean that two
stays on all right and just somehow make
my face a smile right okay I'm floating
in this like from our hot jar right yeah
and then I'm gonna have all these
buttons like outside the [ __ ] jar
there's like a panel with a bunch of
buttons right and one of them will
probably say Gilbert mm-hmm so if you're
still alive you can press it and
Guilbeau Oh personalized messages France
Italy yeah pink dick George right if
you're still alive and you'll get a look
giggle cuz you can see still see me I'm
smiling right and you know I mean what
do you think happens when you click file
here khaila
yep don't eat George Oh neater but
George don't either but it's something
like that yeah
no but eat George something but um yeah
I mean I wanna have hundreds of you know
min this is so thought out yeah cuz I
literally have thought about it
holy [ __ ] yeah where I am yeah I'm gonna
have all that and then um I wouldn't
decompose right in formaldehyde no
but then you don't get used formaldehyde
how do I do it
formaldehyde thing well maybe you could
stuff me like what you call it taxidermy
yeah
taxidermy me and then you can do more
with my body like I can do like a like a
hop in the sky you know and click my
heels yeah like this help me up and then
have the buttons slowed him up that'd be
cool what are buttons
I'll depress computerize buttons or you
could do a flat screen thing maybe like
yeah scream we'll just have like an iPad
they're like machines we can just push
yeah you could just kind of press and
you have a glossary but what if like you
thought I was your friend and then
you're not on the iPad yeah you're not
one of them yeah that's all you get
excited your arms like this and you go
under G and they're like there's like a
thousand G's yeah but there's no Gilbert
real scenario I can't wait to do this
okay where's that where's that where's
dad
where's Bob we didn't put my name I
would put that you would okay ready dude
scorpion killing it he's calling the
show I did 20 years yeah I think that's
not a bad friend a bad idea for burial
pot I don't even want that anymore and
here's another thing it's like we've
been listening to sword and scale on the
drum right yeah back and forth and I was
thinking about this like if I died if I
was murdered
do you know what I want what I want I
want a death I want them to find my hand
hey wait hold on you might be X you know
telling people to know they're not gonna
be able to do this okay tell them to put
my challenge right when one of my hands
in Brazil but then it's like a toe in
Germany like have a part of my body in
every part of the world what we're in
every continent right they find my head
in Alaska yeah I mean and my dick and uh
the Philippines
yeah it is funded in a ditch
you know man yeah that's how I want to
die that well how does that even happen
I know that's well how about you and I
don't know and I would be like a mystery
I know but you could just also died from
natural causes and I could just disperse
your you know body parts all over
the world I can do that for you why
would you why would it have to be like a
murder mystery that's true but it's cool
yeah yeah what about this then what if
they found my dick in Mars that's bad oh
that's badass yeah how do I get up there
well you were in there for five years
already that's right five years I was
like yeah then I disappeared up the of
the little space thing yeah that'd be
cool huh
[Music]